foreign
let's go to Kansas literally let's go to
Bethany on Kansas what's up Bethany
hi Dr John how are you doing partying
dude how are you
I'm good just chilling out in the cold
weather here in Kansas
how cold is it today
well it says 40 but it's been cloudy and
just gloomy and rainy for several days
now so it just sounds gross yeah it's
been that way here in Nashville and the
sun came out today so hang in there it's
coming it's coming it's open okay so
what's up how can I help
um so my question for you today is
um really just so I'm
only in my second long-term relationship
and
um I just you know I gain a lot of
advice from everybody around me um but
it's always terrible Bethany you know
that
most of it's good but it is I guarantee
you it's not the it's not it's the worst
how old are you
I am 36. okay you just said the way you
said this is my second long-term
relationship you said it as though
something's wrong with you do you think
that
you know I've questioned that through
the years what um uh because I'm you
know in my mid-30s and I just had my
first long-term relationship when I was
34 so I was just
kind of what happened with that
what happened with that one
so he was looking I I just by the end of
it I was just feeling more like his mom
than anything because of you gross don't
kiss your son yuck good yeah it was it
was not great all right a quick aside
men grow up okay now we're back Bethany
geez 33. unbelievable okay so if you met
somebody new
yes gross
he's wonderful oh gross okay
why yeah what makes him wonderful
um he's a grown-up
no no he has a really good heart for
people
um we align on a lot of things
um that are very like core values for
for me and for him
and uh we've done a lot of talking the
serious talks
um and we've been together for six
months
and we're starting to talk not really
even starting we've you know talked
about future and what all that looks
like so my question really is like how
do you know really when you're ready to
ride or die as you say with somebody and
um like best practices to prepare for
like marriage well that's a good
question
um the very unhollywood truthful answer
is
when I decide
from this day forward I'm gonna wake up
every day and choose to love this person
I wish there was like this like when
they crossed this magic threshold and
people will tell you all kind of stupid
things that they've got on posters in
their Church office or stitched into
some pillow at the Grandma's house
whatever
love is a decision it's a choice that I
make every day sometimes multiple times
a day
and my wife makes it sometimes minute by
minute right
um so it's it's really when you say it
I'm parking the bike here for the ride
or die analogy I'm parking the bike here
and this is where I'm gonna be
and so that leads me to the next there's
a couple of questions that I always like
and they're little they're a little
untraditional they wrap up some of the
stuff that you would hear in normal
normal like is he the one or is all that
kind of stuff
um the first question I always want to
know from a couple
is where do you all go in times of
disconnection or distress
here's why like from each other from
life
are you somebody who when there's an
awkward conversation at work you
disappear
do you get loud and start swinging do
you freeze and just freeze up
um does that happen in a romantic
relationship does it happen with kids
does it happen with the person at the
grocery store here's why we often try to
solve the fighting or the hiding or the
yelling and we don't realize that it's
the exact same core issue it's just your
your body does one thing and my body
does another
and so what you often get in a
relationship a a romantic relationship
is there's an issue the issue is you
came home and said hey we were going to
talk about the budget and there's a 400
expense at some ammo store not that
that's ever happened in my life and and
instantly you have a deep a defensive
mechanism that just kicks in maybe it's
fighting maybe it's getting really loud
and pissed off maybe it's hiding
it is I'm stuck going to bring this up
I'm not going to say anything and I'm
going to let the slow Ash of resentment
burn he on the other hand when you bring
it up gets real defensive this is my
money I work hard and he's gonna I wanna
know where each of us go during times of
disconnection and distress
and here's the the key here is when my
wife I am somebody who I I kind of
toggle which is weird it's rare
um sometimes I I my chest comes up and I
start to start to fight and sometimes I
hide my wife she pulls away that's just
that's just the way it goes now I know
when she starts to pull away her body's
telling her she's not safe
it's not because she's got some
character issue or some flaw it's that
her body's trying to protect her and I
can then go to the mirror and say what
am I bringing to this that makes the
house feel unsafe
see what I'm saying usually it's I'm
being Reckless with spending or I'm
I've got bull I walk in with bags of
gummy candy and she just knows oh no
he's about to fall off the wall right so
it's it that's that's question number
one question number two is
how do you tell
asking each other how do you like to
hear things that you probably don't want
to know
and this ranges from
hey you have a booger in your nose
do you want me to make a joke about it
do you want me to say it very discreetly
do you want to just not know
to here's how many people I've slept
with
to here's how many people
um I don't I don't like it like when
we're having sex I don't like it when
you do this versus when you do that like
how do you want to hear things are going
to be hard to hear the way you talked to
me last night when you were mad makes me
want to leave this house how do you want
to hear those things and let's try to do
our best to can I honor that
if somebody says I don't ever want you
to tell me I don't ever want to know
you might say I'm gonna tell you so this
this might not be a great relationship
um or like my instinct is to make jokes
about things
that's just how I handle uh hard
situations that's really helpful when
I'm going into a crisis situation and
somebody's passed away and there's
really hard things to see and then we
can make a really
dark black humor joke and almost can
kind of
like giggle through it right
um I learned early on my wife didn't
like me going oh you know what I would
love to do it no kiss you except you got
a booger on your face like she didn't
that
that that hurt her feelings that was
that wasn't cool what she would like me
to say is to whisper into your hangout
burger right there
just be really matter of fact and direct
facts of your friends just say it and
then we move on I had to learn that new
language right but when she said can you
do it like this I was like absolutely I
could do that that wasn't a big deal to
me okay so how do you tell each other
things you probably don't want to hear
that's number two number three the the
big ones the role of religion money and
sex in the in their our
our relationship how do you deal with
this personally how are we gonna do
those things here
um and here's the big one how do each of
you respond when those things change not
if but when
my relationship with faith is very very
different today than it was when I
started dating my wife drastically
different there's been seasons of me
being a devout atheist like just almost
Prof like proselytizing and there's been
Seasons when
um so in tune with
my faith and belief that um it's hard
there's there's not a lot of space for
anybody else and my wife has been
through ups and downs in her particular
Journeys we've just we all chose at the
beginning to hold those things really
Loosely it's not my job to make sure she
believes everything I believe but that
works for us some people couldn't do
that
right and so what's the role of religion
what's the role of money for me money is
very scary for my wife it's this amazing
opportunity
and so we respond to it differently we
spin differently we save differently so
what's the role it plays same with sex
um so you see what I'm saying the what's
the role of religion money and sex and
then here's the last one what's the role
of kids and extended family
this does has um this guy that's just so
wonderful gross Bethany
um has he uh has he been married before
yeah
um and she
like how like I know I don't really have
a say in their relationship
but as we do go into this like situation
she does depend on him financially quite
a bit and just kind of got her and her
Grandpa like sort of wrapped around her
finger and that and uh
and and I'm looking at the future of
like you know if we extend the Family
expand the family like how how do we
have that conversation how do I have
that conversation or I don't know
[Music]
that conversation sounds less about he
can't afford it or less about there's
things we want to do together for our
dreams but he's still paying for an
adult and it sounds more like I know
that grubby little girl I've I've seen
her before and she's just taking this
man's money it sounds much more personal
than financial
yeah
ah Bethany you're my favorite call I've
had in a while
um
so that's going to be a you issue not
him
where it's going to be a hymn issue is
if you find yourself quietly low simmer
disrespecting him because he's still
paying for her
right if you have a hard time with the
way that he if you think you're going to
gently steer him away from his daughter
you're not going to You're Gonna you're
gonna cause havoc
yeah and I don't I don't want to do that
I know you don't I know you don't I know
you don't but you also want her to grow
up I've seen girls like her like you
want that too
um yeah I think that's that's going to
be a place where
try and bite your tongue on that one
where it will come up is when you start
to say okay well when we have this
conversation about the role of religion
the role of money the role of sex that's
really a role of what kind of Life do we
want to live
and in 20 years when you're 56 and
you're 58 what house do you want to have
what town do you want to live in where
do you want to be and there's no
guarantee we're ever going to get there
but at least let's at least aim at
something and begin formulating a plan
let's reverse engineer plan to get there
and that's when it's like hey you're
still sent a thousand dollars a month
your 23 year old kid that's a lot tell
me about that and it's probably gonna be
he feels guilty over some divorce and he
still feels like he needs to fund this
thing because he's paying this out of
guilt and that happens all the time and
he's gonna have to come to the choice
that he doesn't want to do that
yeah
yeah I
I think there's a lot of guilt in it of
course there almost always is almost
always is
like he raised her so of course
um there's also
um have you taken her out for coffee
just to get to know her
um not one-on-one not yet it's still
been kind of a
get to know her with
with him around and so she hasn't is
your dad still around huh is your dad
still around
are you fully you around your dad and
and your boyfriend
no no you're not no you're not uh my
father-in-law's in town and I wore a
long sleeve shirt just to cover up my
tattoos and it's my house in my house
just out of respect just trying to be
respectful and so
um I tell you that to tell you you're
not getting to know her with her dad
around
right you're getting to see how she how
she curates Her Image when old man's
around but you don't know her
um I I would I would lean in there
because you're going to find a lot about
her
um you're gonna find some stories about
him that you don't know
um you're gonna find out a lot about how
she's been raised how she's operated and
for both really good and you're gonna
have some like whoa I didn't know all
that and that's part of the picture that
you are choosing to opt into if you're
with this guy and I think that's I think
that's amazing it's just you just want
to make sure
the car looks great I just want to drive
it first
yeah and what role does your family play
three hours away so
they're just kind of
their advisors a lot of the times but
I'm talking about Christmas Thanksgiving
holidays birthdays funerals
yeah
it's important to us and and
that's his family because it's a he has
such a small family
um but for my family like it's a big
thing let's have all those conversations
up what's the role of kids in extended
family
yeah that is important does that sound
good
yeah hey I'm proud of you
for asking these fun hard questions
well thank you for allowing me to ask
these fun hard questions
it's your life you can do whatever you
want I here's the one thing I would
challenge you and him on I would create
a spirit of Adventure when you're asking
these questions not a spirit of Law and
Order SVU inquiry in court
what's how do you believe how do you
function with religion what is your
thoughts on sex that's so like geez I'm
not gonna fight you now my defense
mechanisms are coming up
but if we're going on an adventure
together hey we're thinking about
building a life
what's the role of faith and religion
plays in your world
um is this scientific method something
you worship or is it a cool way to solve
science problems like like tell me about
what you believe tell me about what you
think what's the role of money place in
your life did you have a lot growing up
did you have none growing up like let's
let's have a spirit of Adventure about
these questions and by the way every one
of these questions will change
ta-da that's the big secret nobody tells
you about they'll all change
and so the second question here is
probably one of the most important ones
how do I tell you things that you
probably don't want to hear
you don't want to know that I used to
love it when you did this thing in bed
and then four months went by and I hate
and now you think it's the greatest move
it's your best move
that makes me want me won't not be
around
how do you want me to tell you that
because you're going to feel embarrassed
that for four months you've been coming
in and doing this thing how do we have
those conversations because it's going
to shift it's going to shift and it's
going to move and that is the Grand
Adventure of being married to somebody
and it's not something to be scared over
to run away from it's something to
embrace fully and be like oh awesome I
get to have a never-ending adventure
with somebody it's fantastic what a what
a rad way to live it's awesome hey hang
on the line Bethany I'm going to send
you the questions for humans for dating
couples and for romantic couples gross
and um those gonna be on me I want y'all
to go through them you'll have a blast